Speaker 1: Starting two days ago, there was
this question What about a domestic travel
vaccine requirement to get on a plane simply
to get on a plane in the U.S. from one coast
to another?
Not internationally?
What about requiring vaccines?
Major controversial aspect that is being considered,
Dr. Fauci saying it would be reasonable, but
I'm not saying one way or the other whether
I'm recommending it.
The latest news is that Joe Biden now says
if his medical team advises it, he will issue
the domestic travel vaccine requirement and
the anti-vax people are going absolutely nuts.
President Joe Biden said yesterday he would
impose a mandate that Americans must be vaccinated
against COVID to travel domestically if his
medical team recommends it.
When asked when he would make a decision on
that, he said When I get a recommendation
from the medical team, the idea of mandating
COVID vaccines for domestic travel has been
bouncing around for months.
The emergence of the Chron variant caused
the White House to revisit this question.
Biden said last month he would wait for the
scientific community to give him a recommendation.
Fauci said Monday anything that could get
people more vaccinated would be welcome and
said that it would be reasonable, but that
he doesn't necessarily expect that, he said.
I doubt if we're going to see something like
that in the reasonably foreseeable future.
Jen Psaki last month said it's not being taken
off the table, but it will depend on the medical
and health experts.
So there's two interpretations of this medical
and health expert thing.
On the one hand, it's very refreshing after
the prior four years to hear a president say,
I'm going to listen to the medical team.
It's not about what I want.
That's great.
At the same time, Joe Biden has sometimes
used this.
I will wait for recommendations to really
just do nothing, and we've seen that used
it in a couple of different instances outside
of COVID.
I think it's really important, just to be
honest, about what such a mandate would achieve
and what it would not achieve this if you
do a vaccine travel mandate.
The biggest accomplishment that it would push
is getting more people vaccinated.
We have seen that when people are polled about
would this or that convince you to get a vaccine?
This is polling people who have not yet been
vaccinated, and at this point, the vaccines
have been available so long that there's real
questions about, you know, what?
What, if anything, would get those people
motivated.
The $100 bonus was not a big motivating factor.
But when people were asked if you were required
to have a vaccine to fly, would that make
you go and get vaccinated?
And that was the the one stipulation that
got the highest number of people to say I
would, and it was something like 40 percent
in a poll a couple of months ago.
So such a requirement would get a lot more
people vaccinated, I believe.
At the same time, right now as Amr Akron becomes
a larger and larger share of the infections,
the effect on keeping infections down is going
to be modest.
It will be greater than zero.
There's no doubt about it.
It's believed that in fact, actually that
if you have three doses, you are up to 75
percent percent percent protected against
symptomatic COVID.
But there is a real question as to what it
will do overall for spread versus keeping
people out of the hospital and alive, and
it will do a lot as far as that is concerned.
It would be crushing politically, I believe,
to Joe Biden in the media to do a vaccine
travel requirement domestically.
But if you look at the polling of what people
think just generally in the general population,
it's not an unpopular provision.
I think this is one of those things where
if there were to be a domestic vaccine travel
requirement, right wing media would go crazy
and there would be some very loud voices saying
it's absolutely terrible.
But the.
Country seems sort of 50-50 on such a requirement,
and half the country already hates Joe Biden,
I think it's basically the same half.
I think a lot of the people that already hate
him are the people against the vaccine travel
requirement.
So it is not something I actually expect to
see any time soon.
But Joe Biden says he would certainly be willing.
Let me know if you think it's something we
will see.
I do not believe we will see that any time
soon.
Remember that on January 1st, we will be doing
our 2022 mid-term kick off membership special.
This is going to be a harebrained discount
if you've been thinking about getting a membership
in all the great perks that come with it,
including the Daily Bonus Show.
Just get on my newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
You'll get an email on January 1st.
You'll be able to sign up at that great discount
and hoping to kick off 2020 in big fashion.
Very, very big from the standpoint of memberships.
Remember that the David Pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you.
We have a membership program.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
the benefits are extensive.
We do an extra show every single day called
the bonus show for our members.
Every day there's an extra 15 to 20 minutes
of programing in audio or video format just
for you.
You also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show.
And when we do these recently, they've been
monthly viewer town halls.
We did one last night.
In fact, our website members get priority
access to participate in the town hall somewhere
between a six and eight time higher pop possibility
probability of getting on with me during the
town hall.
So sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code better 21 21,
almost being over almost 22 now.
Coupon code better 21 To get a roughly, I
think it's like a 40 percent discount.
It's it's pretty solid